[Music]
sorry frog in my throat would like to
announce that my stand up special my
fifth stand-up special is airing on
netflix january 26 which is like next
july 26th that's now
sorry i am
hey it will be also there july 26th it
will still be up in january in january
let's start again you know what please
enjoy it uh and you know what i watch it
if nothing else so that i can prove that
i can remember words for an hour
straight
when we're on the podcast i know i'm not
always uh firing at all cylinders
because i'm disassociating half the time
but on my special you'll see my brain is
intact here's a little sneak peek
give it up for my good friend and yours
yeah
there's a documentary i need you to
watch immediately why are you
complaining about this miracle in your
living room i'll turn this song off in
three minutes
daddy daddy daddy daddy and i deserve to
see this v-neck and this dick that is
the move that's illegal in the nfl i
would like a big beaver magazine please
i've made 74 nickels for this bullshit
shit we put it on our face
we can plie down to the spelling bee i'm
on the moon
it's like two crocodile eyes coming out
of the pond it's dark
no
should we just get in the van with that
guy
[Music]
i feel like that was good can i have my
ring please
she doesn't get it
[Music]
i know can you believe i'm not married
um
that's the special it destroyed my knees
so i hope you enjoy it
can we start now though this is actually
fun sure please are we going pat
rolling what do you know what do you
action okay did i do it right
um
yeah actually can you put it back on
this on the screen yeah so i could see
it well you want to place you with you
you're your own competition at this
point yeah i just want to see if i did
it right i think it did it was actually
really good that's good it looks very
good all right it's sick okay you could
take it i like that now that you're
married you look divorced yeah i would
just look married on the way in
i walked in and you said i look married
now and now you think i look divorced
which one is it well now you're sitting
down maybe it's because you're sitting
so low or something i don't know
do you purposely make this lowers at a
power thing why are you six inches
taller than me magic yeah why are you
ray romano's brother
am i on the podcast with ray romano's
brother like what whose podcast is this
okay well why are you what am i in right
now what is happening
did uh did emma take away your um
platform loafers when you got married i
think she did i don't know i sat down
and immediately you were in this power
position i feel very uncomfortable i you
know i like the new set this is great
thank you i mean it's not you know it's
like a comic book store for female
school shooters
i mean
you're a fucking maniac like if i walked
into this room if i walked in here like
if this was the first room i saw like
we're going back to your house right
calm down everything's gonna be okay
we're good we go back to your house and
you're like oh yeah here just like uh
hang out in my living room i'll be right
back
i would fucking run for the hills or
whatever you they're called out here
what is it called again uh holler
scholars yeah wallace that was a pergola
or whatever
a pergola no that's puglia you were just
in italy we get it
i was i mean i don't know what to tell
you
honeymoon was nice i do need to
apologize for what i wore to your
wedding oh yeah you look fucking dumb
you look like a breakdancer can we get a
picture of this
i always feel like you wore it so we
could discuss it here no no no look at
you what renaissance fair were you going
to i was what is happening right now why
why did you and look at the shoes go to
the shoes you're wearing green uggs you
were wearing like green uggs
i was well first of all
photo this i look like a whore from
middle earth
it's december i'm gonna wear dark green
i forgot my i look like fucking chucky i
forgot my hair was that nasty
riddler color yeah i look like riddler
side chick poor yeah and that's weird
yeah zoom in on my i was also in
blackface
fully
did you see my tanner was just peeling
off yeah i noticed that i didn't want to
say anything about it
yeah that's wild could someone have hell
i'm so sorry like i don't even know but
it didn't it didn't it seemed like you
were trying to prank somebody
like even if you look at your nails it
looks like you're you're aunt frank like
i think
she's been in the attic like you look
like you've been in the attic you know
what i've been looking for things to do
like
addict
i don't know about that you look great
you look amazing
you think you had big boobs that day
don't you think they look a little wild
i don't think they look as wild as
sometimes they look oh oh yeah you have
summer titties like
like in the summer months you have
bigger titties like but like your winter
titties are regular but come fucking
july well they yeah it's like right even
right now i noticed when we were outside
well i'm wearing a bra that keeps that
is a minimizing bra a minimizing and
they still look big
right now even with the minimizing bra
yeah you're a summer tit bitch
[Laughter]
i think i'm a little bit obsessed with
your i loved it
all of a sudden
there's a title for this episode
summer tip bitch but these by the way
this is what the minimizer does it makes
your tits all pointy so my tits look
like your dick now they're all like
points yeah point at the end pointy's
the best like old school like like mad
men titties like yeah like super madonna
yep we like sharp angles back in the day
maleficent i
i'm really sorry about this you don't
have to be sorry i really
felt no i'm apologizing to myself i'm
not sorry to you i could have done
better yeah let's talk about how you
should feel um
no let's do that i think that's good
keep it up because it'll inspire more
things
yeah i just remember like looking myself
in the mirror and being like stay out of
the photos just stay out of the wedding
photos i mean it's gnarly fucking
they're like oh carrot bottom came to
the wedding
dude
if i could just get out of this wedding
unscathed
jesus
it is it is like you're like a lesbian
trying to prove you're not
do you know what i mean like that's just
suspect yeah
no i didn't
you're a pumpkin spice not gay
a pumpkin uh spice cum chateau yes um i
had the best time did you do you have
any what happened at the show
because the wedding was the best day of
my life and i'm not saying that like
bullshit like
the fucking i don't know like the doper
mean overload the serotonin you feel
it's just awesome so it was it was
absolutely incredible a robot trying to
explain love yeah
yeah
i mean like
i
yeah i don't have words to explain it
maybe there's songs maybe pull from uh
that's what it do i i mean i can't
believe i'm gonna quote an actor but uh
ethan hawk had like a really what i
thought was a pretty cool thing to say
he was like once your wife turns 50 you
leave her oh did he um thurman
married 10 and when she gets older just
leave one of the first real tits i saw
in in life right in person yep oh where
breastfeeding at a restaurant okay that
could have gone
it was going to be breastfeeding or
crime no no no no no she didn't rape me
or anything like that okay no but she
popped out that titty at a restaurant
and i was like a busboy or something
like that and i saw that fucking thing
dude yeah yeah it was crazy jalopy no
she had them nancy pelosi's dude she was
she was just
nancy
yeah
i love that
now that everyone's obsessed with butts
you're on you're back to tips what's a
butt
this is our entire correspondence like
you know has giant titties oh i didn't
know queen elizabeth had such huge fat
fucking tits it's like the
whole thing i didn't know that was the
whole thing i thought her being like the
queen's brown jewels
her tits are so giant yeah they're like
a big square like wheelbarrow titties
they have to like wrap them up but it's
a whole thing really yeah she is giant
you saw the pictures i said yeah the
pictures look great her her tits are her
entire like torso yeah you've seen her
it's like posture crouch over it's not
great the purse isn't that heavy yeah
that's true i mean yeah yeah she's got
that fifo from
shit
yeah she's awesome she's on some five of
them like major
like that's some osteoporosis that's
like when you're like oh your tits are
like dangerously large yeah she got
dangerously big tits um i want to talk
to you about this special because you
uh got notes you didn't like them yes i
wish i got more notes on specials i wish
netflix on the last one was like hey
don't spend 200 000 on a sex robot um
[Laughter]
not a sound investment you got notes you
didn't like let's talk about the topics
and piss some people off yeah uh notes
abortion joke a michael jackson joke a
ted bundy joke and um
originally they were good with it yeah
and then
culture changed a little bit i think hmm
and then they were like not so good oh i
assumed it was like trans stuff or
something no not even but i think it was
the trans stuff that freaked them out
okay because there was trans jokes but
not
not only they wanted you to cut i don't
even have any trans jokes to be honest
oh interesting what is i'm just curious
about the tran the obsession with trans
women with men i have a couple theories
okay go i i think that uh go okay the
first one is that um
guys love their clubhouse
okay you've got boys only treehouse
we've got our codes we've got our
secrets we're lord of the flies okay and
if someone defects it's a loyalty issue
it's a it's uh they know our secrets and
they're gonna go tell the other team
it's like you think trans women like
like
leave
the man men
and like run over to us and like they
jerk off all day they try to set their
own dicks they taste their own cum like
like like
i've tried to taste my own cup
i know it was urine
i'm being serious should we call a
physician no when i was young i was
first jerking off i didn't know what cum
was right so i would just jerk off for a
little i didn't even know what orgasm
was so i would just jerk off and then
wait i would pee and then i just put my
finger in front of the stream and go no
big no it's p i didn't come
but once you did start coming well no
once i came i knew i was like oh this
shit different opinion like yeah this
shit is completely different than peeing
like peeing got nothing on coming i
don't ever want to be again
it's coming for me like that but before
that you don't know any better so i was
just throwing the pinky in front of the
stream
and then you know it's like these are
these are i think guys worry like when
that's not it
it's an interesting theory okay but it i
i there's no insecurity that our secrets
are gonna be transferred i remember when
tom brady left the patriots yes
went to tampa everyone's like he's gonna
give the plays to the buccaneer like you
know what i mean like i know i think
your theory is interesting i'm just
saying as a guy and speaking other guys
i haven't felt that insecurity for them
and i don't feel that insecure what is
the because my deal is if a trans woman
they're fucking a guy when you don't
want to
so being trans and by guy i mean like
yeah it's not even tricked right because
it's like but yeah i guess being
traditional but here's what here's the
thing that is that is troubling to me
and let me clarify okay and my shit has
changed after i had like i've spoken to
trans people and like i had a trans porn
star on the podcast daisy taylor she's
fucking awesome
and um
i 100
believe her
that she
feels she is a woman i know trans i'm
sure a lot of people lie a lot of women
you know they lied right that just to me
means they're women
but the thing that we can't try the
whole thing is like well they thought
they were trans
what if they're lying about i've known
people that were knew they were trans
when they were four they're now 35 still
trans yeah this is a real man would
never commit to anything that long
no this is the disconnect i think it's
like and i think women you know are
missing this as well it's like when you
see the women come out and and kind of
like bash the trans chicks it's like
trans chicks aren't at least in my
understanding from when i spoke to him
they're not going hey we're just like
you and biologically female
we're going i they're going weird we i
speak on powerful trans people no
they're going like
i feel like a woman inside i know i got
this guy shit yep so i'm doing the best
thing i fucking can to feel
like the person that i believe i am
early on
and this is what convinced me they were
chopping their fucking dicks off right
okay
to never orgasm again
and that shit blew my mind i was like i
don't i don't want to never be able to
orgasm again but to be able to sacrifice
that to get like closer feels better to
me than orgasming isn't it
and
feeling and looking more like a woman
that they know that they're they don't
feel and look like they know when they
look at their penis they're like that's
not ladylike right right right like
that's why they're tucking that's why
they're doing these things so it's and i
think that's the disconnect i think
what's happening with the trans
community now is very similar what
happened to like with race relations in
america where like
you know like white people like just
like in the last 10 years found out you
can't just touch black people's hair
do you know what i'm talking about i
guess what happened is like
if you're white and you grow up with
nobody else but white people you don't
know it's offensive to another group
right there's so few trans people so few
the chances you have a friend that's
trans
are so little right so you don't even
know the little things
that they are irked by right and the
only trans people most people know are
the most extreme versions right the ones
were like i'm gonna swim against chicks
you know what i mean not the girls that
work at fucking sephora and they're like
swimming girl give it a fucking break
yeah yeah yeah like
as far as i've concerned with all the
trans people i've met hates women every
single one yeah
bathing suits not the best for them it's
not it's
[Laughter]
my understanding they're like yo we got
way bigger issues i don't know what the
hell is going on with this sports thing
like i don't i the thing that really
confuses me i understand the fascination
but
the
like
that now it's okay for like six year old
men to just talk about high school girl
sports all day like do you have money on
the game like why are we doing it's not
about that it's just like it's like an
easy thing to have an opinion on that's
not costly but is also kind of edgy
may i yeah
was women's sports going so well
what do you mean like
was it a thriving bit like
no i mean it's good for the business if
you look at it i think it's more just
like have you been to a high school
tracker it's virtue signaling this is
hard to watch it makes it more
entertaining and by the way i'm a female
comedian i get to weigh in on this i'm
basically in the wnba oh
if there's a really funny trans comedian
that's a woman i'm like bitch get up
here you're one of us yeah you're one of
us i don't care about any advantages you
have i just want another funny bitch up
here yeah i don't i don't know about the
advantage i really just think is people
don't understand it like and i think as
you get older
you know
what is it like everybody eventually if
you live long enough you become the
bigot it doesn't matter how progressive
you are like the most progressive people
in the 60s right now are sitting here
going like
what do you mean they got guys with
vaginas
do you know what i mean the most
progressive yeah
people right there so it's just what it
is yeah yeah there's a joke about this
that i'm trying to think about but like
like before the before
catholicism took over europe
like they were just fucking kids like
crazy like every painter had a kid they
fucked sure and then catholicism like
stopped boy fucking like crazy and now
we just think of catholicism as like the
boy fucking religion
and like there are priests there who are
like do you know how much boy fucking
would be around if it wasn't for us like
all that you would be fucked can i ask
you something do you know what i'm
saying like isn't that like and but they
can't say that
we're bit they're like we're barely
fucking them but like we're barely
fucking them like there's almost none of
them getting fucked compared to back in
the dude michelangelo was plowing out
boy pussy every single day right and
then paint in the ceiling they would
paint them and that's why you painted
the fucking ceiling there was a good boy
that was at the fucking vatican he's
like i don't want to leave yet i'll keep
painting all of those human-sized men
all have baby dicks but that's because
they found black people and it was like
we got to do something
like hannibal was coming over and they
saw like black dicks and they were like
whoa that's vulgar
don't let the ladies know about that
like there's a moment in history that i
think ties in almost like
identically with the punic wars where
it's like big dicks became bad and it's
like the second the african continent we
enter we've got to separate the whites
yeah we met white women and black men
not blacks and whites we just really
this is more of a self-esteem
actually
um so that is fascinating to me what are
the other areas right now where you're
like this because i'm kind of obsessed
with this moment in time because
everyone's like oh it's so hard to be a
comedian right now what no about the
trans thing i think i think what's also
happening is
i think both sides are concerned
and they're both concerned about kids
and i think it's kind of no no that's
when no no no no no no no no no no no no
years ago no no i think it's actually
endearing because like
the the the liberals are the extreme
liberals are very concerned about trans
kids and they want to make sure they're
okay and they want to make sure they're
like heard and they can like be
themselves and conservatives are very
concerned about non-trans kids following
a trend
and there are adult trans adults
molesting their kids that's also true
which is by the way i this is something
that i'm like i have really bad news for
parents like drag queens they don't want
to fuck your kids like drag queens
especially do not want to fuck your kids
the drag thing is very big they won't
even hug their friends yeah like i you
can't because the makeup i have many
drag queen friends you can't touch them
you can't get near them they to molest
you they would have to take off so many
pairs of spanx it just logistically it's
not possible yeah and it's so because to
me louis had that joke where he's like
uh it was something about like
gay marriage or something he's like he's
like you don't want to explain to your
shitty kid like what being gay is or
something like that and it's like
yeah
i
i don't want to have to explain to my
four-year-old what tucking is
like can we wait fucking six years yes
you were right
louis that's accurate i don't i don't
need my four-year-old coming back like
so there was this like really tall woman
who like had balls hanging out the back
of her butt and like a bulldog a little
bit like what is what is that and then
i have to like yeah i yeah i probably
don't want to do that until they're like
nine you say it's a hemorrhoid can i
just go nine
is that crazy
have we lost our minds okay so i want to
explain everything to my kid at nine
okay so this is the kindergarten drag
show
we the teachers can't teach what
happened to naps what take a nap
drag your ass over the fucking nap area
and then take a nap how about that but
like okay but you realize that drag
queens are basically like better clowns
why do we like clowns
your kid was like i want to be a clown
you'd be like get those fucking clowns
away from me like yeah we're having a
clown
hold on hold on hold on if the clowns
were coming around your kid your kid was
like i want to start being a clown you'd
be like we have to make cr clowns
illegal we cannot have clowns near more
kids
i don't want my kid to be a fucking
clown okay but if we have drag queens
around the kids and the kids start going
i want to wear heels and i want to be
like of course you do
all of that
isn't that crazy that's a good point
i just i i also think it's a little bit
wild because it's like the drag queens
are traumatizing the kids by reading
them children's stories every children's
story is so fucking traumatic while
they're reading old yeller whitney drag
queen's the problem where's the budget
for this
that's what i want to know it's in
public schools i went to public school
yeah
that's a great question where the fuck
is the money i don't know are they
selling candy bars and the tupperware
what what yeah i don't know where's the
money for this like for the drag queens
i'm just saying oh they're oh they're
killing on only fans they they don't
need they don't need your children yeah
i don't think they're getting money for
it it's probably isn't it some charity
thing but to me the craziest thing is
that people worry a drag queen is going
to molest your child and the clown isn't
a clown
naked there's way other things
yeah listen
my shoes are there just to hold a kid on
to kick a kid up
i don't know
i find the drag queens very entertaining
like i think drag shows are very
entertaining they're very fun i agree
there's also just
there's a lot like i'll be honest i
don't even think kids get the nuance in
a drag show like i don't even think they
get what's going on like no
to them it's just like barney it's just
no no it's it's actually the most
offensive thing huh like they're just
laughing at the guy that's dressed as a
girl
instead of yeah it's ridiculous yeah so
it's like it
i don't know i think that like the way
that a kid enjoys it is like oh you're
stupid looking but it's just as a woman
yeah but an adult is looking at and
going like oh shit your dance is
choreographed with the song and like
this outfit and you're actually being
this person that was a pin-up from the
50s and you have puns and plays on it
there's inside jokes these kids aren't
getting any of that they're going look
at that gigantic woman that's funny yeah
so it's like it doesn't do any help to
anybody am i i don't think it does i
don't think we i don't well what but
what does video games what does anime
like what like
uh
stick to be already i don't i don't give
a fuck
i don't give a fuck
did i mention that in the beginning
but here's what i do because you're the
perfect person to talk to the shit about
so i can't talk about this shit with
anyone else so i do find it kind of
hilarious what drag queens are going i
need to fucking dance for kidnapping
like where are these dragons
they're i don't drag queens it is very
difficult to get them out of the house
that must have been something that's
what i'm saying i don't think that this
is a big issue and i don't think that
drag queens even want to do it people
making it a big issue like first of all
acting as if the drag queens want to do
it they're doing someone a favor let's
be very clear with this
somebody is asking the drag queen that's
their fucking cousin please can you do
the show with the kids and the drag
queen's going this fucking bitch like
she invested in my company fine i'll do
the fucking show she bought me this wig
exactly like they're begrudgingly doing
this thing like there's not like i don't
believe that drag queens are like
conspiring like let's infiltrate the
youth with our shows like no i don't
know
i just i'm obsessed with sort of the
preoccupation with it you know because i
do think there's a little bit of an
obsession of hyper femininity because
like
what are you do call them now bio
women's system we all dress like bull
dykes now yeah like there's no
femininity left in women why do you
think i think it's just like you know i
mean look i was always kind of a tomboy
do you think that you're a guy i don't
think i'm a guy i'm saying growing up
here's the thing when you grow up
without do you have a long clit
i don't think so
do you talk
[Laughter]
um i do though want to circle back to
it is interesting that when boys get
molested like the cat no one cares
there's no march
the catholic church stuff
interesting like we're more yeah we're
more concerned about female millennials
there's no no if a boy gets molested
like at three it's like we just like let
it blow over and if an actress was
hugged for too long we have to shut the
business down
isn't that if someone's hand was on
someone's lower back like we have to
just shut it down until we until we have
new laws and rules and uh give speeches
about the oscars but the literally
hundreds of thousands of children that
were fucked in the ass yeah by a guy in
a robe yeah we knew what that just like
harvey yeah
uh no one cares yeah it is interesting
why don't we care and i was trying to uh
i was thinking about it because i was
like what where what charity is there if
you were molested it usually just turns
into alcoholics anonymous like that's
where you go no it's true and those
meetings take place in church oh my god
so you're back at the philippines can
you imagine
cena the crime well because also if you
are a priest that molests a child they
give you immunity and they send you to
the vatican and then you're so
i'm always like i don't want to molest a
kid but you know that would love a free
trip to italy well here's the thing if i
get a guaranteed fight
if i fuck one kid i get to go to italy
but yo here's the thing why like they're
they're stuck between like a rock and a
hard place because it's like
if they
if they don't forgive
the molester priests
they don't believe their own bullshit oh
right it's like forgiveness for
everything
so
i feel like they wrote that after
you think maybe there's been some
adjustments over time to the religion
you think that might have happened
you think constantine might have mixed
some things up
okay i don't know what why like puny
wars and constantine all of a sudden
what he just went to italy he was
reading pamphlets the whole fucking time
constantine
come on he's the guy who made uh italy
catholic or the roman empire catholic
but don't you feel like there's like no
focus on those kids yeah i don't think
there's as much i don't know for like i
don't think we see like young boys as
vulnerable and i think we see young
women as vulnerable
and like uh
yeah like i don't know for some reason
it's like
i don't know
they don't even wipe good like it's just
like a weird thing voice yeah so it's
like
oh they're butt yeah
you're fucking some
some shit yeah is what you mean like
you're here's the other thing that is
here's what's hard here's what's hard to
okay so this is why this is such a
difficult time because
when someone says here's what i'm saying
no no no you stumbled and you stumbled
onto the perfect
which is that when someone says molested
i everyone's head goes to a different
place yeah what do you think is
molesting well the problem is when
someone says that then you are the
weirdo because you're imagine i'm
imagining a guy in a a robe like jerking
off like like
like tiny chords like sucking a little
dick i don't do that what do you picture
when you think pl priest molesting child
i just i i picked shit on the priest
i'll tell you exactly what i picture no
i picture like
sean penn mystic river um just walking
around boston with a leather jacket like
that's that's
yeah i don't imagine what happened i
imagine like what it turns you into so
this is why nobody can talk well see i
you can't even imagine it it's
unimaginable so no one can do anything
about it i do think we should kill them
though
sure i think if you molest i think that
should be but what about the fact that
many molesters if not all were molested
it is what it is yeah like i don't care
how you got there right you gotta go and
then you gotta stop it how like what
like a just aspiring squad or how would
you
[Music]
why don't we do that that's a weird
question it is mind-boggling
that we don't do that if because here's
the thing i think that like eight and
below death penalty no questions asked
eight and above
what not nine nine nine is when we're
teaching okay nine okay nine i think i
think no 17
and below oh
okay well okay you're you're for women
you're taking a lot of of cars off a lot
of 16 year old girl's hands and i don't
appreciate it okay i i don't okay let's
just slow down all right this is what do
you mean it's not fucking saudi arabia
okay okay okay this is what you're
trying to have right now when is a kid
fuckable that's the conversation you're
trying to have right now sure
you think you're in for this bitch
i'm gonna crack this youtube algorithm
if
what are jokes they'll cut out of your
special for five hundred dollars please
[Laughter]
i was laughing so much during this
interview that i'm transitioning so it's
a
do a cartoon character i feel like
that's what you do on dates
i literally just got an insight to you
listening to a guy like that oh my god
laugh at their shitty jokes
and then i go on a date with them and
i'm like cool story and they're like
cunt because the bitch is like you
you're already blonde you don't have to
laugh like that
we get it your teeth are straight
is your boss attacking you all the time
are your employees pathological liars
now a word from our sponsor better help
better help is much more affordable than
in-person therapy you know who's looking
for a new therapist too and it's not
because we have boundary issues in our
relationship but i just heard graced it
yeah yeah i'm looking for any therapist
what happened um
the magic died she's like the therapist
i hired to help me quit this job
couldn't put me over the finish line my
therapist keeps saying whitney's side
which is so annoying
so i have a new one too i've had people
tell me that
i've had people be like so i told so i
told my therapist about all this and
they're like well when you make a couple
good points you probably should go to an
allen meeting and i'm like yes
that's why i needed a therapist why do
you need a new therapist um i just uh we
lost our spark oh no we lost our spark
the spark is gone
but what is that because it's because
when you have better health you can very
easily a huge therapist yes okay match
with a new therapist under 48 hours if
you don't vibe with your first therapist
that's nobody's fault like no you need
to have a similar match you need to feel
like safe to share stuff you have to
like and also sometimes it's like you
start therapy and you're working on like
relationship issues and then you sort of
like fix that problem then you got a new
problem or maybe you want to find
somebody who like is more specialized
than that yeah that could be something
too and thank god for therapy or the
three of us would not be existing
therapy is probably my existing
other people would be banging my head
into a shower wall that's what i would
be doing listen get a therapist that's
the most important thing and our
listeners can get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com whitney before i
was in therapy
i thought everyone around me needed it
right and that's usually a sign that
maybe you need it when this person needs
to go to therapy and this person needs
to get their shit together and this is
like but i am perfect it's like that's
probably a little sign that you have uh
you're like you need to go welcome to
betterhelp.com whitney that's
betterhelp.com
with me before we go back to our amazing
guest do you want to go over your tour
dates uh sure i'm gonna be in all kinds
of cities uh coming up my i have a
special
huh nope go ahead i was just gonna help
you out with the dates because i got
them locked in because i know the
calendar
september 9th is going
good luck getting in any of my showers
right now with the amount of dog
ants and dogs um okay so my special is
coming out on netflix july 26th i will
be doing all new material on this next
the tour hasn't been put together yet
because mommy's ty ty huh are we allowed
to say when you're tourists when you're
here autumn fuck i want okay all right
okay
okay
okay
if you want to play by the rules you go
back to snl sweet pea do we think
anybody from netflix is listening to the
podcast imagine 450 people just got
fired
450 listeners
hello
emily just picked up one of our rothy's
flats
by the way hold on emily this is how low
emily sells demons give me that shoe
give me the shoe give me the shoe give
me that shoe emily she's now strangling
herself
she'll be cute she to make a fake phone
out of the shoe
to not like
get the car to put the part the banana
the banana's facing the wrong ground
like to put the soul of it on your face
instead of being like i'm gonna do this
bit but let me like not get leprosy
dirty in this
athlete's face
so this is when the date is going really
well that's betterhelp.com
emily
september 8th i will be in cincinnati
ohio at the taft theater this is going
to be a brand new hour um it's going to
be rocky
uh but that these are those are always
the best shows it's when i'm like
working out kind of new material
cobbling it together september 9th i'll
be in philadelphia pennsylvania you guys
are going to be less forgiving i know
you motherfuckers mariam theater uh
september 10th i'll be in richmond
virginia at the national theater
september 24th i'll be in
charlottesville virginia by the way if
you're watching this i did just kind of
wipe snot off my nose and then try to
rub it away in my like a cartoon villain
so let's just leave it in but what do
you do with snot if you
i took a little but it was just like a
little snot and then i just did this
like casually right now well let's blend
it into my fingertips oh well that's
moisturizing yeah people use snail mucus
for moisturizing they're like he's human
but that's not
i'm sorry i'm trying to positively spin
something emily's trying to start a
beauty brand on this podcast and it's
really embarrassing yeah do that frizzy
hair and makeup on your shirt do you do
that on your own channel
charlottesville virginia i'm going to be
at the paramount theater in
charlottesville virginia also going to
be
visiting one of my dad's ex-wives in her
nursing home dating an older man is not
in my day
was not frowned upon when i was 16 i
dated like a 35 year old
not great creep yes right like back then
before uber or before you know like it
was not discouraged to have let me be
very clear once a woman is like
23 or something like that
she's 40. so
it's like anybody can
have sex with her that's fine there's
also an argument to be made that
men
if i was dating an 18 year old i'd be
the creep because men don't develop
their frontal lobe till they're like 25.
nobody cares about all that
well my frontal lobe i was molested
because my frontal lobe i'm just saying
men are emotionally young
no no no no there's none of that
don't worry about that uh
it doesn't count if you
molest a boy
that has uh pubes
it doesn't matter okay so you're if
you're a girl
like when i was like 13 there was like
one of my friends older sisters worked
at a pizza place with me and she would
just sit on my lap and like rub her ass
against my dick and i would just get
crazy blue balls for a whole summer
working at this pizza place and i don't
feel like at all like affected
negatively by that those are some of my
fondest memories
well okay how you were 13
probably left she was how old
72 72. no no she was probably 18 or 17
or something like that okay
it would be inappropriate the other way
around absolutely
like sitting
on her lap or just to do something
sexual to a fucking 12 or 13 year old
that would be disgusting but the fact it
was kind of like in hillary's pizza
place but i well look it was more this i
think
growing up it was kind of like if you
were younger you were using the older
man right now it's like you don't
believe that but no i listen
i do i think that's part of the reason i
got smart is that i dated older men
young i'm not saying we should do it
that ship has sailed these are the glory
days but if i was dating when i was 16
and 18 year old i would have been just
like watching fucking donkey kong and
video games and shit all day whereas i
was dating an older guy yes he was a
creep but he had like books and he owned
a subway franchise and i learned about
like business and shit did you guys read
a lot of books went to morocco he took
you to morocco at 16. i was like 18 i
think 17 or 18. yeah you got to see the
world yeah morocco
there's obviously a groupon i'm looking
back and i'm like
italy did he try to sell you yes
yeah
it was what exactly happened it was
little armenia in new york yeah um
i was very impressionable at that age
okay
he took me to uh what is that what's the
youngest you'll go took me to zanco
chicken
fine
what is what is the youngest you'll go
with the dude now uh uh i i don't i've
never dated younger guys i've never
dated a guy as young as the guy i'm
dating i don't think how old is he he's
32.
but he's a doctor and he's just a little
he's more emotionally mature than
i think a lot of guys i've dated even
though he's younger but that's younger
so would you do 25 no
would you do 20 no what
i wouldn't do 25 20 yes maybe you'd do
20. that's not true you dated another
guy that was younger than you
oh well that wasn't serious that was not
serious you guys had butt sex so
that's serious is that not serious it
sounds pretty serious to you the
catholic priest did i have to believe a
boy at the time
i think you need to get to 11 you know
well
that's a level of seriousness i actually
do really value our relationship because
there was we i got to know andrew like
we got to be single together
then we had like and then i got to like
see you fall in love with the greatest
woman and make the right choice and i
got to see you with different guys that
you were dating and saw how you acted
with them et cetera this is how that one
guy that fucked you where you shit yeah
that guy by the way are you out of poof
from anthropology yeah no also in the
shower wasn't it a bed that was another
time that was a different yeah yeah that
was a different thing that was uh oh
you were getting i was touch and go
you're getting fucked where you should
yeah i was look i
i
made money and i am now paying the price
um
mad money back then that's what i'm
saying yeah as soon as i got ostensibly
successful guys started fucking me in
the ass really choking me and spitting
on me yeah no because they're insecure
well i just put me in my place or
something i don't know because they're
insecure
you were more successful than me let me
do these things to you
yeah let me make it so you can like are
gonna hobble into work tomorrow i'm like
economically humiliated by you so i have
to sexually familiar
not me but like they are right okay i'm
becoming them well because you and i
yeah i remember i remember i was
this is how not serious those were i
would literally
hang out with andrew and i invite guys i
was dating to like come join so that you
could like give me your input
yes and i would tell you about like raya
they were good guys they were sweet i
liked them they were sweet guys yeah and
then they would just you know
yeah
do that things like
herpes is this normal i do it is going
normal i drive
straight for the butt on like a third or
fourth date that was i think that was
yeah that's what you said to me you were
like you're like why do guys like just
go right for your butt and then i was
like what
and you're like you know how guys will
like just try to i think you said like
they'll just try to like stuff your turd
clipper like immediately and i was like
i did not say it
maybe i said that i might have said that
but uh but uh
but well normally you like have sex with
a vagina for a while and then you
pretend you missed the whole and you're
gonna hear it like there was no like
i've never done that there's no pretend
you missed the hole
like what is that like whose dick fits
into the the ass without like you know
like preparation like i feel like i had
like lasagna like just i need like you
need like eight or nine hours heads up
yeah you need to like eat the right
thing yeah because it's coming out
well it's just like i'm not i don't want
to be feeling insecure and freaked out
or maybe that's what you like because it
makes your butt squeeze up i don't know
it's not i don't enjoy butt sex um
i don't think any do people i feel like
it's one of those things where it's just
such a mental thing sex that so i think
they like something mentally about it
but it doesn't it's not designed to feel
as good that's so true isn't the butt
kind of cold isn't the butthole like a
little chilly yeah it's just dry it's
all calamari like hard yeah yeah it is a
little calamari
right it's a sphincter it is it's like
an anal sphincter yeah and it's just
yeah it's full filled with shit too so
it's like that sucks
it's like filled with it like
it's feeling like it's main purpose yeah
is to have shit go yeah
like the deeper you go the more
guaranteed that you're gonna
bump into some shit the better it feels
the more shit that's gonna be on your
day yeah i also i do feel like there's
an important conversation because i do
feel like a lot of men feel pressure to
do like they feel like they have to do
it to be a man or something now i'd
never have like it's like uh
you're allowed to do it once and be like
that's not for me yeah i i don't feel
that i've never felt like that no that's
interesting yeah it's uh
well no i'm very pro-bot sex now that
women can't have abortions it's the it
is how you should fuck if you're a
teenager can women not have an abortion
no that's it's gonna be a statement and
abortions just get an abortion
yeah i think that um
that's a bigger thing and it's going to
be state by state i want to talk about
now that you are married yes
advice to single women
on red flags
like things this is my favorite
so and they give me the genre of of
female
comedy
is and i'm not talking about just stand
up like women being funny
has evolved into porn sketches no no no
no no no no this is actually i'm being
serious
i
and they're like i think in initially
with stand up it was like women trying
to like do what they saw that was
successful which is like what guys were
doing right
sure whatever it is but like and i think
you just do that because naturally
you're like who's the best i replicate
that like kobe looked at jordan it was
like okay he's the best i'm gonna try to
do that this is normal and what like
social media has done is created these
avenues for women to be funny to each
other now they don't have to make the
guys that go to a comedy show laugh
they can just make their friends laugh
on social media and there are these
threads
that show like female toxicity which is
my favorite genre there is humor that is
for women by women
and i think it's like a really pure
authentic version of your sense of humor
should we have like curves
for comedy you do and it's on tick-tock
and it's funny and like i my girl will
share with me and like i'll laugh at it
and i'll be like this is really cool a
guy would never think about this angle
because it's not we don't have that
insecurity that you guys have we are not
relating to those feelings you guys have
but since women are and there's also a
marketplace for it it's developing and
it's kind of like it's really pure and
authentic and i find it really funny and
then there's the toxic version of it
like kind of where women are just
rejecting dudes for little things kind
of like dudes do you know like being
like the shallow assholes we want to go
away exactly being the exact person that
we that seems like it's replicating what
guys do it's not yeah
this is your version of it you know when
guys like oh i don't like girls with
fucking big feet or whatever like that
but if the most beautiful girl has big
feet you're like i forget of course and
women will be okay with this as well but
i like it it's really entertaining to me
i like seeing women develop this thing
be shallow like us what is the thing
that annoys you
yeah i mean yes that's the well that's
kind of what makes me laugh about when
women are like men are so shallow
they're shallow in a way that they will
drop in a heartbeat
at 1 am they're not shallow in the
slightest it is totally conditional
whatever whereas
guys but guys will be shallow about shit
you can change well her hair is too
short her hair is blonde you can dye it
brown her hair is browning you can dye
blonde she's uh too tall she can take
your heels off we're savage about shit
you can't control we're like he doesn't
have a job you can control it's like
jeez but you know what i mean it's like
at a time where it's most people you
know in america are struggling with
money we're like his credit sucks it's
like yeah well that's different i think
like i think that's sexual harassment
like i think the way that you have to
look at sexual harassment between men
and women is different okay because like
if you're attracted to guys that are for
example tall right like okay
and if so if you walk up to me and
you're like oh my god you're so tall
like that you're sexually harassing me
that's not but that's that's me going oh
shit your pussy looked tight but it is
the same thing okay that is the say if
you are sexually turned on by a man's
height okay that is no different than
breast size and me commenting on it
being like look at those big tits what's
your what do you do for a living if a
girl says that that's sexual harassment
don't ask me what i do for a living what
color underwear you got on i see hey
what color underwear
are you wearing some underwear they got
a color why don't you tell me i want you
to mind your fucking business and stop
sexually harassing me if you care about
if it turns you on if i have a certain
job and it turns you on i'm a certain
height
don't ask me about it
find out who i really am
do you know what i mean like
i'm not some fucking piece of meat
for you to hurry up
yeah like i don't walk up to you and
dude i think it's about sex
to me if a guy's talking like oh if we
are in trouble you could reach the apple
yeah because yeah you know what i mean
yeah like we're you know i think
sometimes it's threat assessment yeah uh
sometimes but i guess i'm not talking
about the biological impulses i'm just
talking about what it means six five
pussy
i think what i what
what comes up in my brain and says is
this
what people i believe would say to that
argument is
that there's not a
an imbalance of physical prowess whereas
i can go like you're so tall and cute
and you can be like let me see those
titties and then you and then i'm scared
that you said that whereas you're not
scared of me when i say look at you tall
glass of water you're not scared for the
physical safety but what if i said like
just charming like that i love it when
guys i was like talk about my body i
love it
i miss sexual harassment i'm not like
back by construction zones every chance
i get nothing but but here's the thing
you don't
leave here no
ever
[Laughter]
on your bodies like that interesting but
we can just equate it and showcase how
normal it is i don't disagree i think
it's more i think it's like i think
everything goes i feel like in the
opposite direction like it's it's this
interesting you know binary thing it's
like uh young boys want to be bigger
right teenage boys they want to be
bigger bigger and then young girls want
to be smaller you know it's like it's
like guys are we taller girls want to be
small like there's all these kind of
things that i feel like just started
changing and i think that um
i don't sexual harassment is a tricky
one because the same thing with
molesting i'm like what are you talk are
you talking about hey sweet tits are you
talking about someone sticking their
finger in your pussy at starbucks under
your skirt over correction
yeah i just don't know that's what we're
dealing with right now i just don't know
there's a big spectrum within sexual
harassment when someone says i was
sexual ass by this man i'm like i do
need to know what happened to understand
what definition you're working with yeah
did he say something that was
oh actually did yeah did were you in a
position where you couldn't do anything
about it i think that's really the main
thing yeah like if it's your boss
that's weird i don't think that that
should like i have a weird thing with
that like for example i never hit on
women while i'm married but before that
like i would never hit on a woman in the
gym
yeah and it's just like
i there are two things that i would do i
was talking to my wife about this you
don't wait till they're on that machine
where they're strapped in and then it's
like i got her she's locked the fuck in
no
no i just didn't do this it felt like
you're there to work out like i don't
want you to feel uncomfortable going to
this place and it was just i felt weird
another thing i would do is like if i
started a conversation with a girl
as
genuine
friend uh-huh i would not ask for her
number even if i was getting vibes from
her big time
because logic there
i think that women need to know that
sometimes guys are nice because they're
nice
and
i think too often every time a guy is
nice to a girl they're like trying to
fuck me right and i was like if it's
meant to be with this girl i'll bump
into her again and something will happen
or she'll reach out to me
but sometimes it's refreshing i think
to just have a conversation with a guy
yeah and then he's not like yo we should
like do something now if i start the
conversation in like a
flirty kind of fun way i'm being
authentic i'm being pure with you like
i've i you know my intentions but it's
still fun and we're being cute but if
i'm genuinely like just talking to you
about a thing or we're talking about a
book or a news article or something like
that and then we're getting along and
clicking i don't turn it into sexual she
can
and then i'll be like okay we can do it
but i mean
if she had been emma would you have
i
i mean like what what do you mean by
that like if had if it had been the one
would that still have been your approach
if it was the one then we definitely
would have met up something would happen
you would you know what i mean because
my thing is like all of our rules kind
of go out the window when it's like
you're you know what i mean like we have
all these rules we followed and it's the
person and you're like all bets are for
when it's the one i think it's a little
bit difficult yeah maybe i'm a hypocrite
in that regard like when it's just like
so maybe undeniable
but
if it's just a girl where i'm like yeah
i'm attracted to this girl but i don't
really see us maybe becoming something i
don't want her in my house
that's never we'd never think about that
i literally that is my thing it's like
hooking up with someone it's like do i
want you in my house my brother once hid
his checkbook when a girl was coming
over and i'm like i don't know she's the
girl
[Laughter]
he came to me is when we were staying
with my parents and he was just like hey
can i give you my checkbook and i'm like
what's up and he's like he's like yeah
this girl's coming over and i'm like and
and there's like well i don't want to
like take the checkbook or anything like
that and i'm like you're not letting
this fucking
woman into this house
also if you can't find a crevice to hide
your checkbook in you cannot make her
come
that's also probably true
that's also probably what are other
things that girls are doing that's a
little cringe besides comedy on tick
tock no i don't think that's cringe
no but i'm interested in that because
you're like okay i love the
self-awareness like this is the stuff i
find funny
the uh
like um
fuck what is it like
like i'm gonna mess it up it doesn't
matter but like there's all these
different versions of like you know how
like people are working from home and
like the girl
just bothering her husband because
you know she has nothing to do and she's
whatever like i i'm gonna completely
butcher this but it's just relatable
like this idea like yeah i'm just gonna
go annoy him like i i to go do i'm doing
the worst job of selling this i wish i
had everyone knows what you mean
everyone knows okay good and it's like i
find that funny and a guy would never
think about that and the the angle in
which a guy would do it would be
critical and
it's self-deprecating coming from the
women which is really fun it's like look
at me being annoying which is what you
guys know we already are yeah and it's
like cool i'm playing
i'm playing into it i'm leaning in being
more annoying we know you think we're
annoying why not have some fun with it
let's go i'm gonna annoy you extra
that's where i am now where it's like if
people think i'm a bitch it's so freeing
cause i'm like oh now i can just like be
a bitch
i can't change your you made up your
mind about me at this point so why not
enjoy it yes i like this i like it i
like the algorithm i want it to show me
i think everything's good yeah keep
going with the algorithms but what are
other things that girls are doing like
little things like we talk about this a
lot like you know how i know i'm old
i got an instagram ad for tylenol
that's because i mean
[Laughter]
usually you get ads like oh you're
talking about like oh look at the
bracket challenge for like the ncaa
tournament right like there's like a
gambling site like something else and it
just was tylenol and i literally wrote
scrolling it like my thumb was a little
sore and i was like yeah i think i need
some fucking towel
like it was perfect so
something's cause something's happening
but go on
that is kind of rough when you start
getting these like targeted things like
oh damn but it's like that algorithm
kind of roasted me right there really
close stay here
under eye wrinkle cream easy guys seeing
how many filters i'm putting on shit but
like i think i see a lot of of and i you
know i've talked about this before but
the like conflating empowerment with
entitlement like i know a lot of girls
now who like they think the coolest
thing to be or do is like i don't cook
shit i don't know any i don't cook any i
get heat up a pop-tart like over
correction it's just like okay so you
are just useless like yeah useless like
that's not helpful you know i don't
protect women
who i'm just saying like that's the male
equivalent oh interesting i don't
protect i don't provide it's like i
don't breastfeed fuck that baby yeah
that's is that attractive like if i went
i don't provide yeah i removed my
biological impulses right like you
cooking is not like uh it's not like a
hobby it's like millions of years of
evolution we have to do it three times a
day yeah
someone had to fucking cook some shit
you know what i mean it's like a bitch
like i don't drink water you see that
that's shit
so like shit of course no guy is going
to be into that i don't know i think
we're at a weird time where like women
are trying to be unfuckable and like
[Laughter]
yeah it's just it's just so odd
it's so awesome
yeah it's so it's like either like
either like you said like the whole like
tomboy thing like trying to like
neutralize their bodies strangers that
follow them like they'll never meet but
not the person they're with i guess i
mean my dude always says to me he's like
can i have the girl in the photo yeah
where's why do you care more about how
you look there like where is that girl
he's always like he'll come home and
because a photo will go up on social
media he'll come home and he'll be like
oh yeah and i'm like what he's like i
thought you were all and i was like what
do you mean he's like well on your
instagram and i was like oh no that's
you i don't even know that was the photo
i'd make like i looked cute and he
thought that it was taking that back it
was going down yeah and then he just
comes home and i just am like
in a muumuu and i look like mrs roper
and he's just like who's mrs roper
who's that
who's mrs brooke you never watch three's
company
i don't know probably it was john
key
balckie yeah
i don't think so threes companies oh
that's perfect strange what's suzanne
summers oh and which by the way suzanne
summers big hero of this guy because
this bitch was on a sitcom was like i
know what's happening i'm the dumb hot
blonde on a sitcom my days are numbered
she knew exactly what andrew already
knew at 30. it's not cute anymore and
25. she
25. gotta what's your machine she thigh
master invented a machine
all the money in the world
what are you gonna sell
not a comb
i just lost my diet smoke endorsement
[Laughter]
you need to tap into all the people you
need to do like a cigar box or something
yeah you got to do something i'm not a
big fan of the cigars like i'll do them
with the boys but it's not like my
inclination too it's not like cigarettes
low-key like i'm like fighting that
addiction big time were you a smoker
never see that's why but i love it dude
it gives you a little kick right does it
give you some energy you know what it
does
you know
do you know
do you know okay
do you know
well
you know it creates separation
like i don't know it doesn't get you
high
but it just creates a little bit of
distance between like you and everything
that's going on so you're like a little
bit unplugged but not so unplugged that
you're not aware but i like that little
bit of separation and alcohol
it can create that
but like
maintaining that moment of like buzz
is difficult
because you either chase it and then you
go over and now you're like drunk and
you're like this isn't that fun right
nobody's taking me seriously yeah or
you're beneath it and you're like
this sucks this is pointless um
especially with people that have a drug
that works that cigarettes are just
great we have so many drugs that work
and we just stand up working all the
stuff and uh
it's interesting because this is so
embarrassing to say which is why i'm
stuttering but i think part of the
reason i enjoy cigarettes not only
because i genuinely
i dated this guy who's a pediatric
anesthesiologist he's like a lot of the
reason that cigarettes are so relaxing
is you're actually just taking a really
deep breath i was going to say that it's
it's like uh meditation you are just
like yeah
which we don't breed like that normally
and you're focusing on that breath you
have to focus on it because you need to
breathe in the smoke i thought yoga
instructors were so full of shit when
they're focused on your breath i'm like
i don't need to do that if you add
cigarettes to yoga it's the greatest
thing ever
like every yoga mat should come with a
jewel and you just
do that for 20 minutes and it will be
the most relaxing time in your life and
there's also something i think that
people like we work so hard and you're
pretty good at celebrating like it's
like is what i can see you know but i
think sometimes we have a hard time
celebrating because and and the next and
the next and the next and sometimes when
you smoke a cigarette maybe it's just
because it's what i've seen in movies as
you smoke a cigarette after you've
accomplished something but sometimes
when i have a cigarette i'm like
yeah
i fucking nailed that do you have any
right now i do can we smoke yes of
course grab a cigarette my cigarettes
are in my car because i don't smoke them
what kind do you have they're american
spirits is that appropriation yeah
that's good oh no we're in cancelled no
this is good native american spirits
they don't like to be called that
indigenous spirits they don't like to be
called that either the first people's
sig pers first people's fag
is that it is that the way to do it
native american fags
no i'll go get the cigarettes okay
they're in between my um the seats in
the car okay okay thank you that is this
is actually exciting because i also feel
like i don't know why there's something
kind of just like glamorous about it i
do get more think like i do feel like
this little burst of creativity yeah and
there's something about just
the glamour of feeling like it's hurting
me a little bit it's like yeah sometimes
i think like these hobbies that we pick
up
just tap into our biological impulses
and needs it's like
smoking is just focusing on your breath
like a cigar like these guys i just like
being with the boys having cigars it's
like no you're really just like taking a
moment and focusing on your breathing
you know i mean like we were talking
about this earlier like i just love golf
it's like you just like being outside
you just you got to hang out looking at
the trees you got to hang out with a
friend you like grass
you like ponds it's ok you like nature
you get to have a friend you like to
hang out with your boys and enjoy nature
what just say it you want to hike you
golfing is hiking you love you went on a
hike you loved it you're like a duck
you are you're a duck guy you're you're
a duck guy yeah
that's your duck yeah you're going to
visit your dog it's like every success
give me a cigarette do we have a lighter
way to clear up the cigarettes too
that's they literally are
native american facts
like look at that what is did they get
permission to do that isn't it more
offensive than like the football team
you know what lgbtqia community is very
proud i am proud to be a smoker
i am proud of shit do not do this at
home i don't encourage this we're only
doing we're micro dosing nicotine it's
the new high performer shit
is it hard for you blondie
we're going to talk about um
we're going to talk about cbd because
there's a lot of rigmarole about cbd a
lot of charlatans out there a lot of
hucksters a lot of people trying to
bamboozle you can we say that word you
know what even if we can't i'm not
stressed because i have next devo
natural cbd products and they help me
feel less stress and i know what you
think whitney cummings stress
when
okay i had come off
like i've got all my shit together but i
have help
okay it's neither of us she's got no
it's not
and uh this here's i was reluctant about
cbd in the beginning because there's a
lot of snake oil out there okay there's
a lot of people are trying to say i say
berry here's cancer charcoal toothpaste
cleans your mouth yeah doesn't false
okay false right and a lot of people
with cte were trying to sell me cbd in
the beginning oh cte cbd big company i'm
saying emily's
now trying to do a rap career like you
could
you i need a back-up plan
and so yeah
um
so i was trepidatious about cbd in the
beginning because i've i've gotten on a
lot of roads with dealing with stress
and feeling like i just was more
stressed out by taking more things and
mixing things and just you know this is
the only thing that has really worked
for me in the cbd space okay
and because the other thing i i was
weird about with it it's like it takes
forever and you're stressing and you
take a cbd then you're stressing out
like is it my relationship has it kicked
in yet this uh gets into your system in
as little as 10 minutes that's because
of the smart sword technology and that
improves cbd's ability to be absorbed
into your system next evo naturals are
scientifically formulated to deliver
more cbd in a way your body can actually
use it and fast proven 29 times better
absorption in the first 30 minutes and
that's coming from someone who's
self-absorbed and i'm 29. stop wondering
if cbd is right for you try next even
you know how old that sounds to a lot of
people try next evo natural capsules
gummies mints and topical creams
clinically proven to be better absorbed
by your body grace take it away get 25
off your first order of 40 or more at
nextevo.com with promo code whitney
that's 25 off at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o dot-com promo code whitney
why don't you date a lot date a lot yeah
like i think oh you have to fuck a lot
yeah like date a lot like i think one of
the coolest thing about my girl was is
like like we didn't have sex until she
decided
meaning like which is all the sex i've
had in my life
but like meaning like she was like yeah
i'm not doing this you know until we're
dating for this amount of times or until
we've been doing this until you
unfollowed tommy lahren
still follow him
stop liking her videos yeah yeah but
like i just i was like really attracted
by that i was like oh this is so cool
like you're not caught up in like a
moment of lust
oh no
but like oh no what kind of if a woman
does that she's a pig well guys we get
caught up in lust see we i don't think i
think that
i i definitely have got caught up in
lust before but i i'm gonna be honest it
was definitely like
this is how i'm gonna keep him this is
it's insecurity not left yeah i
definitely look back at all the times i
had sex before i wanted to and it or
before i it was not like i just need a
dick in my post like because the chances
of you having an orgasm on a just lust
fuck
is very low
you know so to me it's more like
like i'm gonna keep you interested so do
you resent that
all the times i had sex
no like just yeah just the fact that
it's like
more difficult for women for you
and most women to climax and that these
like random hookups the chances of you
doing it compared to like the guy
orgasming are far less it's just like
far less there's no real reward for
being a slut
well but i don't get if you guys nutted
every time i'd be like yo catch dicks
but like the fact that you don't so like
you add another useless body right and
you don't even orgasm like why are but
why are girls pushing this like why are
like other things feel good besides
orgasms though ugh i hate that fucking
argument who else has made that it felt
good up until
no it didn't wait what is that no i do
think making out is very fun oh no no
these things feel good these things are
great like
making out is great all these other
things are great just like connecting
with somebody's fucking awesome and it's
hot but here's what i'll say once to me
the sex thing i got to be honest it's
more about
having an orgasm you really have to be
relaxed and comfortable with the person
and it's and if if there's not like some
kind of plan in place for how these
fluids are gonna i'm stressed yeah your
whole sex thing is warped though we i
may be cool but you personally it's
worked how so
because like the fact that you're even
thinking like where the fluids are gonna
go you already lost i
sex is fucking gross with a stranger
that is gross so take that in
that's not gross to anyone else no it's
the most human thing that we can do with
a stranger
uh you haven't had a fucking guy spit in
your mouth have you
a guy of no never see you you have a
different guy
there's so many more fluids i like i
like spitting them out
my wife doesn't like it i don't she put
up with it earlier
like hey my girlfriend liked it
my fiance liked it a little less shit
and this wife
wants nothing to do with it
she got that ring and she was like ben
you try to spit it you just hold it up
like what are you doing like
but again i don't know like i guess what
are you doing doing okay can i finish my
blistered pepper please shout out the
blister peppers that you spit in my face
that's the best page on instagram right
now
um that what else have you noticed since
going from uh fiance to husband what
have you learned do you feel you've
learned anything
about human nature
just more
i learned like
like and this is it's gonna seem like
the hackiest thing but it is really true
like
communication but like what i what what
i think that means is like how do you
say how you feel
in a way that's not going to
enrage the person that you are
communicating that to and by
communication it's never like i need to
learn how to say i love you no it's how
do how do i say this thing you're doing
is annoying to me
in a way where you don't feel insecure
or angry
and like that's what like we go to
therapy and it's like it's so fucking
helpful to learn these little tricks
to like
okay instead of saying like i used to go
like put your arms down why do you want
why do you why do you want to fight why
do you wanna ruin the night in my mind
i'm like i don't want the night to be
ruined why are you doing this
the way that's interpreted and the way i
would interpret it as well is like
you're wrong you're doing something bad
you're why would that ever de-escalate a
thing even though we both to de-escalate
it mm-hmm so like
putting it on me i think my therapist
said he was like he was like yeah just
say like what how it makes you feel it's
like ah i'm i'm kind of sad because i
feel like we're going to let the night
get away from us so it's not about what
you're saying it's about how you're
saying it exactly and like that's why
therapy is dope but also therapy is
tricky because sometimes the therapist
tries to like fix shit in your partner
that you don't want to fix
you know
it's like like you don't really need to
wear those short skirts do you no no no
whoa i'm okay with the skirt but like
like little things like you know you
guys are very um you know dependent on
one another and i'm like hold on now
what what what i just say fix that bro
like just don't make her angry like how
do you make her not angry at me and then
it's over after the therapy
like some of this fucked up shit works
bro like
why don't we list the things we want to
fix and then list the things that work
out good i'm gonna need you to read this
book
before i come back
so any therapist for me needs to read
this book and then i will come back
but i love it whenever i
uh have a feeling i have to say to my
head i have to go say what you mean mean
what you say don't say it mean say what
you mean what you say don't say it me
but it's so hard like i think at least
for me too we also came off scary like
when we talk yeah yeah like i have to
literally i go i'm gonna go talk to my
dude about something put your arms down
you can't if you're here
it's already over it's a aggressive you
can't no one's listening to you and
you're also dealing like with
everything they've dealt with in their
life so like the thing like you're the
things that don't bother you at all
might bother them
you know what i mean yes so like
i'm not talking to just my wife i'm
talking to like how my wife
got raised the things that she went
through with her family like her fears
yeah so
when i say something it could induce one
of those fears and i gotta go okay i
gotta communicate that away where she
doesn't get defensive yes and she gotta
do the same with me and i don't know
what hornet's nest i'm walking into so
let me learn where the land mines are
that's safe and then i'm going because i
care that much it's crazy that like
i don't know because you know we're
obviously talking about kids and and we
were both just like yo like we got to
make sure
we're good
because i don't want
there's not going to be time for us to
work out our little shit when we got a
kid it's going to be even more stressful
so let's learn how to communicate with
each other before we bring this life
into the world that's going to need most
of our attention
and one thing i will say to that i guess
because i think i've spent so much of my
time going i'm not gonna have kids until
i'm
fixed i'm not gonna have kids till i can
communicate perfectly i'm not gonna have
kids until i break the cycle and it's
kind of like you know what
like they'll be fine also are you are
you gonna have kids i look i have all
the time in the world what is the rush
what do you mean i'm joking
just do it yeah i think i'm gonna do it
maybe next year i mean you know we gotta
plan tours like two years ahead now you
plan so much what do you mean i have to
why you don't have to do anything
well i mean you just gotta plan around
like you're
like i have to decide if i'm going to
carry it or if i'm going to have a
surrogate i mean you're 50.
you know what i mean you can't carry
anything upstairs let alone a baby
i am totally fine to fuck around with
this i can my i have six more years
until i can i guess easily
you know get the eggs out of the freezer
and out of the bluebell ice cream
container or whatever wherever the fuck
oh yeah you froze your shit froze my
shit yeah yeah yeah but and then i have
to decide if i want to do a surrogate or
do it but you're right look i tore a lot
even if you're not old as a woman as a
comedian you fucking feel old like but
you don't have to tour check my purse
now
the airport i check everything i walk on
the plane with nothing
it's like i'm not carrying anything so
so look i don't know just fucking do it
yeah but i think that i think that kids
for uh as long as you're telling the
truth
as long as you tell them the truth so
the worst thing you do to a kid is you
and your girl are fighting in front of
the kid and then they're like what
happened oh we were doing an acting
scene because kids know what's going on
kids are okay with conflict yeah they
don't learn based on what you tell them
like because they know they feel it kids
know everything they're little psychics
and so if you just go hey we had a
disagreement i was angry i overreacted
and now we're fine then they can learn
conflict resolution they can learn how
to have emotions in a healthy way it's
not realistic for a child to never see
any conflict ever i don't think that's
normal i mean like i don't even i'll be
honest i don't even think kids process
what you tell them interesting they just
do what they see yeah like everything i
learned from
my parents like
i mean everything i learned from my
father was from observing him and my
father was you know he's my fucking hero
so it was like i think he's literally
the greatest
dad that's ever existed and i mean that
sincerely and i and i don't remember
that many things that he's told me like
i remember a few things he's told me
maybe one or two give me some good uh i
remember i didn't do my homework once
when i was a kid and then he asked me
he's like well
i was on the way to school and he's like
well do you want to just stop here on
the stoop and you want to do it and i
was like
yeah i would like to do that and then i
did he was like i'm really proud of you
you did that and i was like oh okay and
i never didn't do my homework again
so it's just like these little things he
wasn't saying do your fucking homework
after you did it he said um he gave you
positive reinforcement maybe just ask me
he's like he gave me the opportunity but
i also saw him like work like great like
my workout that comes from my mom my dad
they work their fucking asses off so i
just expect to work hard and like
my dad was incredibly curious he like
asked everybody he spoke to was the most
interesting person every single person
my dad i always say that's uh my dad was
my sort of first like comedic
inspiration because he was always doing
crowd work no matter who he would be
from man
he would and he always would say he's
like if you're struggling with liking
somebody or like tension with someone
ask them three questions about
themselves yeah and you'll there's no
one you won't fall in love with if you
ask them three questions about this yeah
where are you from what'd your parents
do yeah you know what high school did
you go to yeah and you always knew
something they'd be like oh yeah you're
in baltimore down to main street like
always he would connect to everyone
janitor to ceo dad was from baltimore no
but if someone was from baltimore he'd
be like oh yeah down the harbor like he
would always find a way and he would
even i would watch him even knowing that
like he hasn't been to all these places
but he's like what's that pizza plate
what's the pizza place yeah there it is
gino's like oh yeah like he would always
want to make people feel special yeah my
dad also i think there's just this
narrative i think that girls are so
trained that their dads fucked them up
even when
maybe they didn't like we find any
i think i've spent a lot of time just
like not focusing on the positive and
not focusing on like oh given the tools
they had they nailed it you know because
i think the same way
every one every serial killer like well
the mom must have just not loved him
enough like girls are taught to be like
well it's i can't make a relationship
work it must be my dad's fault it's like
maybe you're
you suck yeah you know what i'm saying i
don't think yeah moms never get any uh
your dad didn't tell you to post that
ass photo it's always the dad's fault
like if a girl is a stripper it's like
the dad miss volleyball like right maybe
your mom sucks dude there were some
trans bitches on that volleyball team
and maybe would have shown up to the
volleyball game i'm just saying
if you made it something entertaining
shout out um but uh my dad said a couple
things that at the time like i didn't
understand and i was like so committed
to the idea that i was like fucked up by
my dad that i didn't even realize like
all the incredible things you taught me
uh and now as an adult um i live by them
number one insecure people are dangerous
he would say that yeah oh wow he's like
never forget insecure people are
dangerous because insecure people
sometimes like oh no don't feel bad
about yourself oh and you want to work
extra hard to like take care of them but
those are the people that are going to
fucking snitch on you that are gonna
gossip on you they're gonna tell your
secrets that are not gonna be loyal to
you because they want everyone's
approval someone that wants everyone's
approval is gonna throw you under the
bus in a heartbeat yeah
he also said something that is very
simple but and maybe i need to uh detach
from it a little bit but it was life is
not fair he always said that to me he
never said life is fair you deserve this
i'd be like i didn't make the t he'd be
like life's not fair
would he explain life to you a lot it
seems like he was giving you like a lot
of
wisdom as to how life
he gave it to me through sports like he
didn't really know how to attune to me
in terms of like having a like the
father-daughter relationship it was
it's kind of awkward like it's i mean
you know like there wasn't physical
contact like a tampon commercial would
come on and i would just run out of the
room if you were watching a movie and
there was like a make out scene it was
just awkward he wouldn't like i mean he
wasn't like loving and like sweet he was
but in a way that looking back it was
his language was like acts of service
and showing he would like write me cards
and stuff but he couldn't really like
but women need that too they need they
need to know that they're
they need to know that they're
interesting and they need to know that
they're like loved and beautiful
chinese as well like you need to hug
your daughter and you need to tell her
that she's great totally and his mom
died when he was young so maybe he
didn't get enough physical contact from
her his dad was in a war and was very
sort of shut down so it was a lot of um
militant like i'm gonna teach you how to
succeed this is how i can love you we
also have to understand like your dad
was probably like alive during the civil
war and like what happened to men that
existed in that time is like i'm just
bummed they knocked down that statue of
him in south carolina i mean that was
like the last thing i had to remember
you were the one protester in
charlottesville
guys
he was a good man
so insecure
um but uh
it's just it was it was through sports
so he i'm just curious why like you you
you really want to know why things work
like even the movie the female brain is
like this is why we are the way we are
and like you look up all these
scientists and you read all these books
and you're analyzing biology and all
this other stuff and it's like you're
looking for like a reason why
the world is the way it is and it's like
um let's say you find that reason i i
think what i have a hard time accepting
it just doesn't the bad things in the
world aren't conscious choices no no no
no no no
things just are
and you retrofit whatever the fuck you
want to
onto this world yes to be able to like
rationalize to make it the best version
for you for the short time you have yeah
it's called religion it works great if
it's not it's religious it's science is
a new religion comedy it's whatever i
think science is too rigid like even
religion has some like wiggle room a
little bit but like this idea like
you're gonna go figure everything out or
you could just retrofit your own
rationale like you know more or less how
to treat people yep
i don't need a fucking
biological reason why i should be nice
to people it makes me feel good when i'm
nice to people i like to see them feel
good and that makes me feel good that's
enough yes and i think that when you
come from people doing maybe bad things
to you you need some kind of reason so
it's like you don't trust people as soon
as you bring up uh we should kill
pedophiles i'm like yeah but they were
probably molested too like i need a
reason why they did that because i don't
think i can sleep at night knowing some
guy just wants to fuck a kid like i
don't i can't yeah that that that
bothers me and i think that's right
that this person was possessed by some
demon or mental illness no no no there's
there's not a reason like there's not a
reason why you're smart there's not a
reason to tell me guys just like tiny
buttholes and tiny dicks you know it
regardless of why it is it is so now
what are we gonna do with it i guess i'm
one of those things that's like
life is the perception you have on it
you know like i can think of the worst
case scenario for every situation or i
can think of what i'm gonna do with this
situation right and i'm gonna go okay
how can this be a lesson or how can this
be something positive you know what i
mean like what can i get out of this you
know like my dad his memory is gone
pretty much right so it's like this is i
could just every day go oh god i lost my
dad you know or
i could look at it and be like more
memorable or
did he really or you just
no no like his short-term memory is gone
but like he's also like the happiest
he's ever been so i'm just like huh
like maybe he's just not holding on to
those like things that used to like
stress him or make life difficult for
him and like he's still handling it with
like grace he's not angry at people a
lot of people get angry during this time
he's not fucking angry like
and then getting a lobotomy or something
yeah like in a weird way and like my mom
threw him this like 80th birthday party
and it was so cool like because it was
all of his friends from when he was
you know for for years now he's 80 years
old so he's all his friends he's known
for 30 40 years and your memory
functions in two ways you have
short-term memory and long-term memory
my dad's long-term memory hasn't gone
yet so like for one night
so he only remembers when you weren't
famous no no no no no
for one night he had his memory back
he didn't really
but oh
whoa everybody that he met he remembered
their name he remembered stories all the
stories that they told so it was like
one it was like i don't know if my mom
realized this but like gave him like the
best fucking birthday present ever oh
wow yeah right yeah it is oh don't cry
so like so it was like the most
beautiful thing and i'm like how awesome
is this i was like oh you're so no this
is from when you call me 50.
[Laughter]
isn't that isn't that a fucking
beautiful thing like
and and they were like dancing you know
my parents had a dance studio so it was
like also the interactions were kind of
short because it's like they're dancing
they're having a moment moving on to the
next one and like
he doesn't realize that he can be
awkward in conversations and stuff
because he'll repeat the same things
yeah but in this situation that didn't
really happen that much and then
it was all the people that he affected
like how many 80 year olds have like a
hundred people show up to a party like
it's crazy like yeah
right
like they should be dead all these
people right
so like i don't know it was really cool
it was really beautiful and i could sit
there that day and be like oh i'm so sad
that i didn't have this like selfishly
i'd i couldn't sit down and talk to my
dad and whatever and i think a lot of
people take that woe as me
but instead it was just like how awesome
is this for him and i'm gonna choose to
focus on like the coolest part
of this night which was seeing him
interact with all these people and
making him laugh and like being the
charming guy he is and it was awesome
and life can be awesome and we all know
it's fucking miserable so we put
whatever
perception we want on these events that
we cannot change and i'm gonna choose to
look at them in the best possible way
and that's just me and i went into i
think
with this with a similar situation both
my parents had strokes within a year of
each other and then someone in my family
had um really
uh
difficult addiction
issues and i couldn't i like i wanted to
fix them all let me just learn
as much about the brain as i can so i
can fix them there are these books about
brain plasticity so this is how we get
this part of the brain back and i was
just so obsessed with like getting
them back yeah you know yeah that i was
like because i also went into um
dads kill me dude dad's oh i cry every
movie that has like a dad issue it's
like
every single time yeah okay
so this is why they but you don't have
to but
you don't have to fix them because i'm
wrong dads do fucking yeah they're the
best dads are the best dude like
they're the best right every movie is
you know dad
it's like where's the movie where it's
like you have to stop oh my gosh but
like here's the thing that i think a lot
of us don't realize is sometimes they
don't want to be fixed i look like shit
on this podcast because it's okay this
is your dad i will fucking this is a
beautiful moment yeah
kill its dad's dude if anyone talks
about their dads i just lose yeah it's
the best because they're the best
they're the best and especially when
they like take time and they like put
time into you and like
you know that to me that meant the world
yeah you know what i mean like and i i
was so uh i was so lucky so it's like
like yeah you could look at it as a
negative but why i also think my dad my
dad was definitely like a ladies man
like women loved him he looked exactly
like dan aykroyd yeah and he would sign
autographs as dan akroy hilarious so
funny and um he
i think when he had daughters like
i look back and i'm like oh i was
watching this man that probably was like
girls or girls and they're you know have
daughters yeah and go like oh my god
like how do i protect them from what up
yeah yeah you know like i remember one
time we were in ocean city oh so shitty
ocean city
too young
with a bunch of guys like in a trailer
he found out where we were it was like a
trailer like ocean city has like
trailers on the beach we're in a trailer
we're like all asleep like drunk
hungover passed out
and i look up and i see my dad
climbing through a window
like a trailer window he's a giant dude
yeah the door's two feet to my left yeah
open
like he was just like fucking found out
where we were yeah and he was just gonna
fuck some people up and he fucking
fought
all these like high school boys
i was fired
damn dude yeah we never spoke of it
again got in the car yeah uh we had a
tape of if i ruled the world by nas uh
uh on a loop it was like a on a loop and
we just kept playing it over and over
again it was never discussed again yeah
he didn't punish us we didn't get in
trouble we didn't talk about it was
never discussed so i think it was like
there was so much unsaid i guess back
then because it was just like so uncle
it was just so awesome you needed a
little bit more communication like every
everybody needs a little something
different my brother needed a little
different parenting than i needed like i
i flourish with freedom you know like
you just let me go and then i i i can i
i know i think that i'm gonna do pretty
much the right thing so don't tell me
what to do because now
i assume that
you're thinking i won't do the right
thing and i resent you for that and now
i'm gonna do the wrong thing can you
talk me through this really quick cause
i did date a guy who we were not right
but i did i did really love him and i
did want it to work out at the time i'm
not i'm not like that all my exes are
crazy i'm like no i love that person it
didn't work out if you think all your
exes are crazy what are you doing it
just makes you look silly yeah so i and
i remember him saying he was like the
key with me he was an older guy he had a
kid like adult he was like the key with
me is a long leash i told my wife this
can you tell me because i didn't listen
and i wish i had um i just told her like
listen you got to trust me like i i i
really like you and like if i ever feel
as if i don't think that this is going
to go somewhere i'll let you know as
soon as i i'm not going to waste your
time i don't waste girl's time
so
i just said that and then she trusted it
and like i'll be honest that's a tough
thing to trust also because there's a
lot of fuck boys out there that might
and i was a fuck boy don't get me wrong
but i was
genuine with her in that moment and then
she trusted it and the thing with me is
that the second that you like restrict
me
i'm thinking about all the negative
things that could happen whereas if you
just allow
this doesn't mean cheating this doesn't
mean like dm'ing whores it just means
just let this happen don't force this
yeah let this happen on my timeline yeah
unfortunately my timeline might be
quicker than yours but if you force me
on your timeline i'm gonna be miserable
but if you just let me do my thing i'm
gonna love you so much let me just let
me drive exactly like hey i'm going to
be late i got to do this spot if the
answer is is that the shape of phone
still
[Music]
that's how old we are
after building that fucking studio you
still
you know if i call you and i go hey i'm
gonna be late because i'm going to do
another spot and your answer is hey have
fun i love you
i i might cancel the spot and then come
home
now i'm not going to cancel the spot but
i'll be so grateful but you don't get i
also if you make me feel guilty i also
don't think you get points for that that
is how you should if you are with
someone you have to accept their job uh
you you do not get to pressure them
around their job you do not get to guilt
them or shame them you can say i'm upset
because i really wanted to see you i
cooked this even that i don't want that
but i'm just saying if you sh don't make
me feel guilty
like i'd rather you
don't make me feel guilty and then quote
unquote let me do the thing also because
now you're not now you're not letting me
do it
also that's on you to adjust your
expectations if it's comedians leaving
for the night
make plans
don't cook a nine course dinner thinking
they'll be home 15 minutes after their
spot time yeah learn it's like what they
say when you go into alano if you're
with an addict
learn about addiction if you're dating a
comedian learn about comedy and how it
works i yeah the other thing that we got
to do though is like a lot of times we
don't want to let people down
so we don't
we'll avoid letting them down as long as
we can and then we end up wasting their
time so it's like i should just go like
yo i'm not gonna be home tonight but
instead i'll be like yeah i'll be home
at eight fifteen away it might be nine
yeah yeah exactly but it's really good
i don't wanna let you down because that
makes me sad yeah but if i if i did it
in the beginning
then everybody would probably be happier
i will have a spot at 9 30 i'm like baby
i'll be home 9 45. yeah before 10 no
question like it is so dilute it is so
disrespectful thankfully he under he
knows how to decipher my lies at this
point he's like that means midnight
you're gonna run into freight you know
but um i the guy that i'm dating i was
so
unclear about what his job was like i
would like facetime him at two in the
afternoon like what do you do like i
went to his work and i was like oh i'm
never calling you again
you're like
i get why you hate me and think i'm such
a fucking narcissist i did not realize
you had like nine
like dying animals like in front of you
at all times and all these employees
like understand what your person does
for a living and if you don't if you're
like don't come home then you don't
respect what they do and you shouldn't
be with them anyway if you fall in love
with someone you have to be in love with
their job on some level or you have to
understand it i think you have to
respect what they do yeah and i've made
the mistake of dating guys that i liked
but i didn't respect their job and i'm
like why don't you fucking leave who
cares and it's like you can't do that
it's also up to us to like respect our
job
and i think a lot of times we're like
people pleasers so we want to please the
ones that we love the most and
sometimes peg you as a people pleaser
you know yeah of course like i just
don't want to please everybody yeah but
like if i don't like you i don't care if
you're pleased or not but if i love you
then i want you to be happy and i it's
better to hang out with you when you're
happy but if that means that i'm gonna
put the things that i need to do
second or even third then i'm gonna end
up resenting you because i can't do
those things that bring me joy as well
so i need to be very upfront like yo
this is what it is
so that
when i am with you you feel confident
that i want to really be with you yes
yes yeah well that's the other thing
because if you if i this is oh emily
remember this
so
i this is we had to go to couples
therapy because
for literally one thing which was
he
my dude thought i owed him an apology
for something and i didn't believe i
owed him an apology for i wasn't sorry
yeah okay and i was like look i can
apologize to you and sell it yeah but i
will always know
that i conned you and it was a fake pot
we're both gonna know it was fake you're
used to people accommodating you
you've existed in hollywood for fucking
how long 60
how
how long have you
how long have you been in hollywood 63
how old are you 63 years old are you 38.
i'm 39. you fucking asshole oh wow i'm
not doing this
okay what is this like i will not do
this
i don't know i just thought that you
were i thought you've been in the
business i think i remember
i i
you're shirley temple right like aren't
you
aren't you sure
this business
creates people i've experienced this
shit on like a very small level like
you'll be on a movie and like everybody
you need a coffee so there's a coffee
guy who gets you your coffee yeah
there's someone who brings you a
breakfast sandwich yeah like so if
you're i'm not on those movie sets but
you for years have existed within a
system that accommodates your time it
accommodates your schedule and like you
have you have people that are around you
that i'm not saying are bad but they are
there because your time is so valuable
that you need it accommodated i'm not
saying i also have this right it's
different hollywood is like the most
extreme version of it right right right
so
i'm sure you're going to expect a new
person in your life to also accommodate
that like you like rescuing like there's
one of the dogs that's in here that's
terrifying like well you're a new yorker
no you guys are scared of like very easy
no no you have one that has a strong
neck
and it just walks around and it is the
scariest fucking thing i've ever i don't
even feel comfortable petting it it's
like at any point in time if it bites
down on me it's taking me wherever it
wants to go
and you have it just walking around your
nice chic fucking home in the middle of
goddamn nowhere wherever we are i don't
think the dog i think the dog was here
first i don't think that you adopted the
dog i think you built the house around
the dog and the and here's the thing i'm
scared of it this is just a giant dog
when i came here i was like where are
the dogs like oh they're in cages i'm
like good like finally this is the first
time i felt comfortable in your home and
then about five minutes ago that dog
walked by that door right there and i
haven't been the same since
you just started talking about how much
you love your dad yeah i was like i need
i need something something i need
something to happen final words yeah i
was like okay we got it i think we got
it i think it's ramona the ridgeback
the ridgeback oh that means alex is here
oh alex is here yeah so that dog
yeah that dog needs to be uh
that it needs to be put down sorry my
dog is not like a fucking paddington
bear
doodle
what they need to be like that dog is
more like what before humans got around
that dog is close dog is a genetic
nightmare
are we on the same page finally
it seemed like we're agreeing you you
know that the guy that made uh is it a
doodle a labradoodle yeah look i just
want to let you know right now the guy
that made labradors has publicly stated
that it was a mistake i know i know and
he is sorry but here's the other thing i
don't care when that kind of bites you
in the face in three years no no no no
no no it doesn't
that thing right there
at any point you this is what you don't
know like you're gonna have one of your
little soirees where everybody does
pagan rituals and whatever and like
drinks fucking blood or whatever you
fucking weirdos do out here and
that dog is gonna fucking tear up
people's necks
i mean this and it's gonna happen and
and then we're gonna go back to this
process we're looking for an excuse to
get a lift that is the perfect i gotta
attack my what face your face new face
dog attacked me i have pimples around so
that when i get a face lift i'm like oh
no it's just reconnecting it's just
reconstructive
i just pet the dog you pet the dog and
the dog looks at you like are you
fucking dumb like why would you do this
like you're putting your hand closer to
my biting thing
it is the scariest dog i've ever been
around in my life the last time i was
here not only did you have it just
roaming around free unleashed with no
muzzle you gave me food in front of it
and it sat next to me looking at me and
it was it was staring at me and it was
just going like i'mma let you finish
this sandwich but if i wanted i just
take that whole fucking thing
it was like you didn't put it away
or anything and that that is your
problem
you have an issue um
you have an issue right right
you have an issue i'm gonna come back
here and i'm gonna i'm being serious you
think i'm joking no no i don't there
there will be a zebra here within three
years
with animals like no no you have weird
things with animals yeah you went to try
to save a giraffe from a fire yes that's
right it's it's that's right i got it
out it took three years got it out if it
couldn't see the fire coming
[Laughter]
if there's one animal that could have
nodded to the rest of the animals
that the fire was coming it's that
giraffe maybe it didn't want to be
around anymore maybe that maybe the
giraffe saw the fire and it was just
like finally thank god i don't have to
be at the winery anymore where people
are spitting fucking cabernet on me all
day as they pet my fucking hooves and
then it was you with your with your
stupid water moccasins or whatever you
went down there where it's time to save
the giraffe i'm here
we got it it was the book of eli you
were you were in your fucking denzel
washington book of eli outfit with a
patch you wore one eye patch for some
reason and you were trying to steal a
giraffe
listen i need you to get it together
how you could take it there
how you could take it there
is beyond
the giraffe before i pose with the
chimpanzee that you have in your house
dude i feed that thing bath salts every
morning
i don't know if you don't you're
probably comfortable with dogs but like
i do this thing where i'm like
oh dogs can sense your energy so like i
try to like pretend my energy because if
you're scared you think at all they'll
get scared yeah food runs too it's like
that's what's tricky if you run then
they think there's a problem yeah so it
is really hard when people come over and
their people are i'm like don't be
scared don't be scared and they're like
um yeah
i'm not yeah i i definitely am not
scared of animals that i will say that
yeah jellyfish is the only thing i don't
fuck with and by the way guess what mr
new york
new york and all your uh my girl got
stung by a jellyfish when when we were
in uh on our honeymoon and i got to take
a hot piss on her i was going to say he
was this you're just trying to you've
pushed her off the battlements he's the
fucking captain of the boat
it cost me 100 euro to park in a
jellyfish
and then she dove headfirst into a patch
of jellyfish and i was just getting that
urine ready
i was drinking non-stop limoncello
limoncello lemon because i wanted to
have like a real color yeah yeah okay i
would have a nice color it's like guys
that think drinking milk makes you fun
more drenched um drenched
peeing on parts that didn't even get
stung
i was like it travels up
that's what i said i was like it travels
up babe we gotta i've only been peed on
one time and it was in the shower but
like on par not like when guys just pee
on you in the shower all the time uh and
i couldn't stop laughing wait what
what do you mean when guys people you
know guys just in the shower they'll pee
and like
oh yeah just no no do you get
no
no
no pat
no every time well guys will pee in the
shower and then you're just like why are
you peeing on my fucking leg no no the
guys i did have some bladder control
issues maybe i mean why shower together
what's the point of that i don't need to
do that it's the finest like who does
that help
you're always going to see the other
person um wash their butt or not yeah
and no guys wash it and no one washes
their legs
yeah do you wash your legs uh you don't
you let it dry you okay so this drives
me now sometimes i do you just let the
soap fall sometimes it just depends you
have to wash your whole body
and guys never do that they're like no
the shampoo up here just washes it i
watch till like thigh
i get my balls and i get my ass okay i
pulled a little toilet paper eyeballs
out of my ass
what about
uh
my little dingleberries i get their
berries out there
i get the berries out i always make sure
i get them
okay one quick i know i have to let you
go soon but really quick now that you're
married what are the precautions you're
gonna take to not let it get
like
like
unsexy is there any like we don't pee in
front of each other we don't fart in
front of each other we don't is there
any precautions in place no not really
no i mean i think that we both got it
like stay attractive i think that's like
important mm-hmm i think that's you know
we both have that we can't just let
ourselves go sure i feel responsibility
and i know that you know she does
but uh in terms of like farting like
yeah i fart like i gotta fart like i
i mean when we were first dating like i
would if i would stay at her place like
she would go to work and then i would
just fucking unleash
i would unleash it
no for real
i got
that's how when you know you love her
like when you're holding in farts for
all like i would take a pillow in the
middle of the night and then i would
like put it over my ass
no no
and i would fart into the pillow like a
silencer like you know in the mafia
movies where like
yeah
so i did that a lot um but yeah like i
i'm gonna do that gross shit i thank god
she doesn't do it
and uh
i'll do it she can't that's the secret
yeah
so she's like i don't fart in front of
you so that's how i am she goes when she
even when she shits she goes i have to
use the bathroom
when she goes to fart no she gets a shit
she goes i have to use the bathroom and
i always try to catch her shitting no
why would you do that
oh god bless how long have you been
ellie i leave saturday what are you
doing the next two days
what are we doing next two days
a couple pods
doug wants to take me to a shabbat
hanging with you hang with me yeah are
you going to come into college and um
well yeah come to l.a and hang out in la
i want to be very clear about this
special
people are going to go to the andrew
shulls.com yes you can pre-order it and
then on the 17th of july it's just
available and it is straight to your
website and it's going to play on your
website with no commercials no
yeah nothing else we partnered with
moment house so moment house is gonna be
the the one that is providing the
streaming capabilities but uh but you
can order we do the live shows with they
have some footage that i really want to
make sure they keep in the vault
we did a live show with them and it got
wild yeah so it's awesome and i'm
excited about it and i think it can be a
i don't know let's see the people the
people ultimately decide but i think it
can be a really cool opportunity for
comics to put out their content if they
have fans and people who support them
and if they're dealing with some sort of
kind of censorship issues or like
networks wanting to edit jokes which is
which is common and i kind of understand
that the networks for doing that i mean
you know they don't love comedy the way
we love comedy they they love building a
business which is great and important
but like
i know i love stand-up and i i know that
the people like these jokes is i perform
in front of them every single night and
i if you if you're in an office you
don't see that so no i i want my comedy
to be exactly the way that i want it to
be and this is a really cool opportunity
and if it works i think you either see
other comics doing it or
you see networks not giving notes
because either way something's got to
give because this is too disruptive if
this disrupts at the other day it's up
to the people but if the people support
it what will happen is
is that the networks will go the only
way we can keep talent is if we let them
do the jokes that they want to do
because we now have another option and
what what i love about this this moment
house opportunity is like
not only
do we put it out and the super fans can
experience it we still own it so what we
do with in the future we put it on clips
on youtube you could still you on the
audio you can put it on spotify you can
select broad dog but more importantly
like you could you could put it in one
place for all the people that support
you they fuck with you they want to be
part of that movement they want to see
the new thing you got like a movie and
then you can put it out on tik tok
instagram and youtube in terms of like
clips where you can get new fans so it's
like the best of both worlds if it works
yeah if it works i don't see why a comic
would ever do anything different
i i really don't yep
i i and again it's that's the gamble i
think the reason why people are scared
to make the game was because a lot of
people don't want to know how much
they're actually worth
well it's also tricky because i don't
want to know how many people actually
watched i'd rather just get a lot get
the check uh you're not going to put i
mean look remember when netflix used to
have ratings and stars and shit like
comics went uh-uh like a bunch of
powerful comics we're like shut that
shit down we don't get report cards
that's that's our nightmare because uh
we
oh well we should coast on some is hype
some is photos of you know like
we can't get down to the actual data
because a lot of people will be
embarrassed but i like the data because
i'm a comic that like i built this with
the people right so it's like it's not
like some big industry was like hey
you're gonna be the next guy it's like i
put shit out on fucking youtube and then
people shared it with each other to the
point where i stole that fucking radio
city twice there was no cheating exactly
there was no cheating
i don't even call it cheating like if if
you show immense talent people want to
invest in you that's great like i don't
got anything wrong i just mean it's pr
it's i i imagine it's an incredible
feeling to go everything i have
i was me and my team it wasn't luck it
wasn't a pr department it wasn't because
i followed the office it wasn't because
i got this lucky break i got all these
billboards and all these promos like we
did get lucky don't get me wrong you
need luck but i hear what you're saying
it feels like
it's it's it's validating
i guess what i'm saying is like my
validation doesn't come from like the
brand name of a streamer my validation
comes from the people like if i sell out
shows that makes me feel really good it
doesn't make me feel as good if i'm in a
movie or if i'm in a tv show like some
people like that you got to force me to
be in a movie yeah you got to force me
to act yeah right i got to love this
movie or love the script or like really
like somebody as part of it like i don't
care about that that doesn't make me
feel like i've made it yeah what makes
me feel like i made it is if
i'm i what makes me feel i made if i go
on a movie set and no actor knows who i
am but the grips are all like oh shit i
love you yeah yeah like i made it
totally amazing
like no no actor or exec knows who i am
but everybody who works here knows me
i made it real human beings exactly
comedy fans comedy fans just or just by
the way i i truly
i have that same i don't want to be an
industry darling when i walk through
like i remember there was a time i
walked through tsa this was like i don't
know maybe like six or seven years ago
and i was like whitney and i was like
this is it done people that work nights
yeah know me people that work like a
real job you know what i mean so like
for me that's
that is the ultimate and i think that's
why i can do something like this and i
think there's a lot of people like they
they just need the co-sign
and i was very fortunate where like i
had to develop
this relationship because i didn't have
a cosign
so then i vow and then i found out oh
how validating it is and now i don't
need the cosign i'm down to do work i
have fucking i'm in movies that are
coming out on every streamer i'm not
like anti-streamer i have projects with
i think pretty much
every one of them
but when it comes to comedy i'm just not
going to edit the jokes because i feel
like what got me here was putting out
authentic comedy and there is also a i
mean it's like when
networks give notes um you're like let
me
you're fucking yourself over
like you just need to justify your
existence i get it because these are all
fake jobs and you need to say something
let's just pretend that i needed to hear
this and great input like i'm happy to
participate in this cosplay of like you
need being having a job like giving
notes on comedy but like let's not it's
not let's not i'm not gonna pretend it's
real yeah i'm happy to fake it and be
like oh thank you for the insight we'll
take a few frames out of this but don't
be like it's the bottom line you have to
take them or it doesn't air here it's
like it's really not that hard oh you're
the guy at the renaissance fair who like
doesn't drop the accent when he gets in
the car
you know what i mean like home here is
one thing you might you might be proud
of me for i am doing only fans first
script or first original show what is it
it's roasts
it's just dirty roasts what's that
instead like roasts what's that
that's not the one
all right hi
hi
new yorker versus dog but what kind of
dog is this hi baby that is a great dane
pit bull
oh why'd you need to put the pit bull in
there
yeah
you didn't need to put the pit bull
that's really afraid of dogs no we're
afraid of fucking horses
frankie come here
he is the sweetest boy did uh giannis uh
saved my life he had to break up a pit
bull fight in that uh bedroom truly he
was staying at my house for two nights i
had a puppy and there were two females
and they went at each other over the
puppy it was the first time the puppy
was like in the mix
thank god my only friend that wears
fucking sneakers was staying over he
darted out and he went full fucking it
was hot he came in and he fucking
separated he knows what to do with
pitbulls too he knew exactly what to do
like save my life i saw or i mean at
least like a couple digits like i was i
was trying to separate them myself and
he like heard it and he ran down and he
separated them
and then yeah yeah okay and that's where
his hairline went um
no i'm doing only fans which is uh which
is basically like it's gonna be roast
the way we used to do roasts where you
could actually say crazy shit but it's
you know on only fans so it's like
instead of dirty photos or dirty videos
it's gonna be like the dirty jokes and
roast jokes that's great and it's all
gonna be our friends that's great it's
gonna be like roasts who are you gonna
roast it's gonna be like i feel like it
should just be our friends
yeah you know well you need somebody
famous enough for people to care about
the roasting of course yes you know
but i think but i still think it should
be comics i wanted to be comics only
this whole thing where roasts all of a
sudden had actors and random old women
from sitcoms well you need someone to
punch
i think that's why those people are
actually important because like most
people don't know comics so it's like
they know famous people so the comics
are there to make it funny the people
are there to be the punching bags but
like it can be like snoop he's great at
it but stoop is a famous person he's not
a comic that's what i mean he's the
perfect person because he can be funny
you know what i'm saying he's the
perfect person pam anderson i'll never
forget the day i'm up there roasting her
and just going in on her pussy and you
have aids and syphilis and i look over
and i just see like
she's like emotion and i'm just like
what the fuck why are you here she was
crying well she was just like my kids
are gonna see this like she was so upset
i mean there's more things they could
see well i did say you've dated tommy
lee
kid rock and brett michaels why don't
you just save yourself some time and
drink a vat of magic johnson's blood
that's good
it was like it was i remember being like
uh i don't know what to tell you bitch i
don't have health insurance i'm doing
this like i looked at her and she was
sad i was like bitch i know what it is i
gotta get new faces you signed up you're
here i don't know what to tell you
so it's i think having it just be like
comics and people that no one's gonna
worry about their feelings or punching
down or any of that shit i just wanted
to be like literally a safe place for
comics to be like really unsafe and like
behind a paywall so if you admitted that
you're offended by a joke on only fans
you're admitting you were on fucking
only fans and you can't you don't say
you can't cancel someone in that
environment yeah you're we're already in
the fucking gun you're signing up we're
in the gutter
where we belong
i love you man love you um i'm so
fucking happy for you thank you so
inspired by you thank you um and
we got to get you doing it next the
andrewshulls.net.com
imagine can you imagine yeah maybe next
who knows who knows if it's successful i
think that you'll see this become a
trend and here's what i'll say so the
special i just a different netflix that
comes out a week after yours i did
finance self-finance and license to them
so i'll get it back in two years and i'm
allowed to put 10 minutes on youtube but
what if you could get it back in two
weeks
and what if you could put however much
you want to put wherever the fuck you
want to put it look
i'm going to finish this what if you
could get the exact same amount of money
that they gave you
plus whatever you make look women don't
know how to use computers i don't know
what to tell you you got a phone
[Laughter]
don't like it
um the great andrew scholz he is my
friend um watch this special you don't
have to like if something
nettles you
that's comedy fun
fine
you'll survive yes
i love you don't write elephants
did i just break something no just
spilled oh no not on that oh my god
that's the one thing that did that get
wet nope
i gotta save it don't ride elephants
guys you know i am these awkwardly i
love you
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
you